salut la maman de jay comment va jay bonjour neil il est
à la maison mettant à jour son cv
promets-tu que ce sera correctement
rempli pour toi
bonne chance pour le reste de ta vie
et essaie de ne tuer personne désolé plus
optimiste que ce à quoi je m'attendais
simon nous devons parler oh  ne parle pas je
pense que nous devrions rompre
maintenant que tu as été largué nous pouvons tous partir en
vacances mentales ensemble
deux semaines de soleil mer sable alcool et sexe
il y a beaucoup de photos nous
allons faire des photos jusqu'à ce que l'un de nous soit assis
à travers notre nez mon argent est sur moi
tu marches juste vers une fille dans le club
et tu te présentes tu danses
près d'eux fais les yeux puis fais les
danser avec toi vraiment reste avec moi
tu iras bien
mec je vais rester coincé  avec un gros puis
nous regardons vers d'autres endroits mais nous avons réalisé que
nous avons été repérés avoir l'air froid
tu es une vierge c'est cool et je pense que
c'est célèbre oncle bien c'est mignon alors
oh mon dieu c'est encore pire vient un film
sur l'amitié
et les moments  nous essayons d'oublier que
tu es anormal es-tu
je vais coucher avec toi c'est une blague c'est
vrai
j'ai perdu mes lunettes
toi